Remember, the only criteria for
whether something would be a fast-forward merge is if the branch you
are merging into is an ancestor of the branch that you're merging from.
This is an example of that.
It's pretty clear.
If you trace back from b you get to a.
So this one would definitely be a fast-forward merge.
In this case you can also get from b to a.
There would be another way to go.
But since this is in the history at all, we do check this one.
Here there's no way to get to a from b.
Nowhere in the line from b to the first commit do we find a.
So here, no, we can't do a fast forward merge.
We would have to create a new merge commit.
Similarly, in this case, a is not in the path from b to the initial commit.
So we can't do it here either.